guys congratulations on a an epic season
it was really a lot of fun to watch
what were your overall reaction once you
got saw how the the scripts were playing
out how the arcs were forming yeah i
mean a lot happens this season right
obviously it's got those dramatic
moments and it's got those that
emotional through line and the heartfelt
moments it has all that which is a
driving force of the show but i actually
felt this season was the the funniest
everybody else could see ben right yeah
and he's a complete [ __ ]
they're all [ __ ]
[ __ ] who can fight
the next person to say [ __ ] is
getting a punch to the throat dick
[ __ ] [ __ ] i really felt like
there's so much fun to be had this
season from everyone you know they all
have their moments actually it was nice
i felt like if we were any more relaxed
with each other we'd be in a coma yeah
yeah exactly yeah sometimes when you're
goofing around on set and doing these
scenes it i mean it just doesn't feel
like work at all and that's uh but i
actually think that's a really good
thing when that happens because you
everyone just relaxes and it's great
yeah yeah i mean right off the bat we
get this uh this footloose dance number
that's really a lot of fun what's it
like
rehearsing for that performing that and
shooting it is that like a whole week of
work well for me rehearsal was just a
technicality because once i won a line
dancing competition
that's a true story
i won a line dancing competition when i
was 12. do you and i won a cassette tape
of some of the best of line dancing hits
you lucky dog yeah it's so it's in your
blood it's in my dna man yeah i didn't
realize i was working for this show back
when i was 12 years old
you know that would be very keeping with
the show
yeah exactly a
time loop
but uh yeah it was good fun to all dance
together you know yeah we did weeks of
rehearsal for that something that
everyone should do i think yeah dancing
together is really powerful because you
kind of your personality dissolves for a
while in a group it's really nice yeah
another really major moment in the
beginning of the first few episodes is
victor
fully becoming himself dear team is good
but i don't think you're better than me
i ended the world twice and you you're
just meeting spandex what was your
perspective when you read these scripts
when you or saw
how it was playing out or being involved
in those scenes
yeah i mean we knew was gonna happen uh
before we read the scripts so it was i
suppose it was a thing of like oh okay i
wonder how they're gonna do this
i think it was handled the way
brilliantly actually and exactly as it
should be and it was handled quite
quickly really but i think yeah yeah i
think it's the immediate acceptance of
the characters of victor
that is
is so well done and i think i initially
when i read it i was like oh is that is
that too quick you know do we not give
enough and then i was like oh actually
no that's what it should be like it
should be
complete acceptance off the bat
because it's it's about someone
dealing with what they want to be not
about the other characters and what they
think it should be or
um
so i think he was yeah i think it was
handled brilliantly actually yeah i mean
you could almost
feel
the love
coming through in the in the screen i
don't know if maybe that's me or like
worse acting what i you know was
expecting when i watched it but it
definitely felt
so warm in a really loving way you guys
did a really nice job with it everyone
well i think as well there was a
crossover
between us as as actors for elliot you
know there's that there is a
an an inevitable crossover there yeah um
so i think you do see an element of how
we feel about it you know it's coming
through the characters when we jumped
here we created a time paradox our
little paradox brought forth the
freaking kugelblitz what the hell is the
cougar blitz essentially we're screwed
by the end of the season we're in a much
different place than when we began the
season which typically happens with the
show but um it appears that our our
group is now
having reset the universe and
powerless
what was your take on that where do we
go into season four
your guess is as good as ours i think
there yeah i think i think klaus is
going to end up working in a nursing
home that'd be great like doing hospice
palliative care you know just helping
people
pass the border from life to death
yeah i think like don't worry about it
i've been there it's nice
i think luther will be working in
abercrombie and fitch as a german
greeter
yeah because he's so happy with his new
torso
yeah i was like to go to work and not
have to put on the suit odd light
very light yeah like something's wrong
yeah it did it felt i felt like anyway
what you know what's weird as well is
that suit
has become a part of luther in terms of
his personality and when i put that suit
on i feel more luther so playing luther
without that
felt like huh this is weird
um so
yeah that i mean you know
if season four you know if we're in this
same place you know and i don't have a
my body next season uh that will be
different for me to play for sure
tom from i mean from a performance
perspective do you
hope that luther finds sloane or doesn't
find slu good question i mean
i don't want to go back to playing um
grumpy luther you know um
i don't think that's sad yeah and deeply
sad luther i think we can do something
more interesting than that but i do
think if he hasn't found slowed it it it
makes it slightly more interesting i
don't know whether
uh the creators see see sloan in this
next season so i guess yeah i don't
really know which one is better really
because we've kind of done the love
story so it's like whether he finds her
and they are just together in this next
season
yeah and for uh you robert i mean klaus
just
fully realized well possibly potentially
realized his
full ability this season what do you
think his headspace is now having it
gone away in just a heartbeat it's very
buddhist didn't it
you create the sand
artwork and as soon as it's finished
just
blow it all away
i suppose you know then
normalcy becomes
utterly foreign and exotic for for us
all
our own
sense of being becomes abnormal
and exotic so
there's loads and loads of fun you can
have with that you know i
talking to steve blackman the
one of the key words in the writer's
room is subversion you know
what can we take that is
a rule in the show that's presumed to be
there as always and just completely flip
it on its head
and so i was
hoping at some point in the show that we
would be powerless
and this series was very power there was
lots of power stuff in this series
and it was very big
visually in that sense
lots of characters all doing their
powers together
in groups you know cooperating through
doing their powers and so so now if
we go into season four and there are no
powers
it's a whole new challenge for the
writing of the show i think
and
i try to think about it not at all so i
can be completely pleasantly surprised
when
the scripts and the story arrives and
you tell me and i go oh yeah nice that's
clever yeah and it's never what we think
it's gonna be yeah it always sort of
surprises us
so uh
so it could be as
you know closer to the dmv or
you know you can just pick a normal such
a boring situation and it becomes
exhausting and strange not coming back
to the dead just rubber stamping next
yeah